are you ready for Gears of War for this
fall well if you want to taste of the
game before the full release you'll have
to act fast all you have to do is play
gears of war Ultimate Edition while
signed in to xbox live before march
first so this is pretty much your last
chance to do it the Gears of War for
beta is coming to Xbox one sometime this
spring but we still don't know much
about the game but a few notable
industry figures have commented on its
development Xbox executive Phil Spencer
said it's making quote stunning progress
and producer rod fergusson said it'll be
a graphical showcase for Xbox one
considering the impact Gears of War had
on the xbox 360 we're inclined to
believe in here's a war for releases
this fall and Ultimate Edition is slated
for PC release sometime this year
remember if you're looking to get into
the beta you should probably sign on to
your xbox one as soon as this video end
and if you're looking for all the latest
gears of war news you're already in the
right place
you